[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE LANGERT: Now while the
Blackhawks are certainly
a core piece of this
story, it's much more
than a hockey or a sports book.
So what do you see
as the central theme
of "The Breakaway"?
BRYAN SMITH: Well, I'm
glad you asked that.
It's a great question.
Yeah.
I mean, I know for those--
how many are Blackhawks fans?
Yeah, everybody here.
Yeah.
See, I mean, that's--
you know, obviously
the juice to the story
is the Blackhawks and
the big turnaround.
What I found, though--
I mean, to me, unless
it's going to be
like kind of a puff piece book,
that's not enough of a story.
So part of what led
me to believe there
was a book there was
digging into this family.
And what I discovered-- well,
so the theme that emerged
is this almost
Shakespearean relationships
between father and son
and brother and brother,
meaning Bill and Rocky.
Just the depth of
their animosity
to each other clashing,
and the horrible way Bill
treated Rocky, basically
excommunicating him
from both the business and
the family, the Blackhawks
and the family.
And then his brother, Peter,
who was with the Blackhawks
and Rocky, and their--
I don't know if rivalry
is the right word.
But they just
clashed all the way
back to when they were kids.
And I didn't know this.
And so I started to see more
of a family empire story,
but just a family
dynamic like we all have.
I'll admit it, I have problems
sometimes with my father.
And I think we all have a
little dysfunction somewhere
in our family.
And it felt relatable.
But-- oh, who am I kidding?
It's about hockey.
And it's hard to kind of convey
that because hockey is fun,
and there's plenty of hockey.
It's kind of the backdrop.
We were talking earlier.
Anybody watch "GLOW,"
that show on Netflix?
It's about the women of
female wrestling in the 1970s.
That's the backdrop.
But the story, of course,
is about these relationships
and dynamics.
And talking about
the movie "Titanic",
which I didn't really care
for-- but the ship going down
is not the story.
It's the love story.
Spoiler alert, the ship sinks.
So that's what I tried
to do with the book.
So I think-- all of you
are Blackhawks fans.
You'll love it.
But even those who aren't,
I think, will like it, too.
DAVE LANGERT: And the Blackhawks
are a part of the Wirtz empire.
But really there's a
much bigger piece to it.
Can you talk a little bit about
how that empire came to be
and what it all encompasses?
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah.
It's interesting.
I didn't know before I
started researching it
and people would ask me,
like, so the Wirtzes,
is that old money?
Did they come up from
some European royalty
and come over here?
The answer is very much no.
It's very much an
American bootstraps kind
of empire building story
that traces the Wirtzes--
and hopefully not in a dry
way, but a compelling way--
from the original Wirtz.
Michael Wirtz was a dirt
poor farmer in Luxembourg,
came over, steamer, landed
in France, went to New York,
and settled in a farm
in suburban Illinois
because the land was a lot
like his land in Luxembourg.
And so the Witzes kind
of spread out there--
I guess near Mundelein--
and kind of gotten
involved with the town
and so forth, but nothing big.
And then this guy
Arthur Wirtz was born,
I think third or
fourth generation.
And his father, Fred, for
some reason left the farm
and went to Rogers
Park and became a cop.
Arthur was born, and
it's still a mystery
where he got this gene from
but he, during the Depression,
was in real estate.
He was cash rich, and he
started buying arenas.
He bought the old
Chicago Stadium.
He bought Madison Square
Garden, St. Louis, Detroit--
there were a couple of others--
and so cornered the market,
kind of, on these big stadiums.
And with Chicago Stadium
came the Blackhawks.
And back in those days,
you could do this.
His partner owned the
Detroit Red Wings.
And they just kind of like--
such a conflict.
Literally, they were brazen
about taking the good players
to Detroit and just kind
of letting the Blackhawks
do whatever they wanted.
So Arthur starts building there.
He also made Sonja Henie--
I don't know if you've
ever heard that name.
She was a figure skating
queen of the day,
and they turned her into--
I don't know, Ariana Grande.
I mean, she was a
rock star [INAUDIBLE]
packing a figure skater.
And they made these
Ziegfeld Follies shows.
It's the forerunner of
Ice Capades and Holiday
on Ice and Disney on Ice.
And so that was another way.
And then he moved into
liquor distributorship.
And now the Wirtzes
are, I think,
the third biggest in the
country liquor distributors.
And I do want to
mention one other thing.
For a time, Arthur and his
partner moved into boxing.
They called it prize
fighting back then, back
before cable and stuff.
And there was one fight,
Friday Night Fights.
And everything was rigged,
and Arthur ruled all of it.
And the Feds finally broke it
up as a monopoly, made him sell
Madison Square Garden.
And there were mobsters
and unsavory characters.
And Jimmy, his
partner, walked around
with $100 bills, dollar
bills in his pocket.
He was like, slicked back hair.
And so Arthur is such
a character in himself,
a book in himself.
Gave birth to Bill,
and here we are.
DAVE LANGERT: And I mean,
Arthur comes to life
in the book in a
lot more details.
My personal favorite is how he
handled a poor earnings report
that Rocky had one time.
Are there any other
anecdotes about Arthur Wirtz
that you can share that may
help bring his character to life
a bit more?
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah.
Well, so you guys
know Bill, right?
He's just cantankerous,
belligerent, defiant, almost,
in his pushing of the fans.
So Rocky told me that Arthur
made Bill look like a pussycat.
That was this his words.
And he said he was the most
intimidating man he'd ever met.
Amazing business man.
But he was like
six four, 280, 300.
Huge, imposing figure.
And one of the best
stories was Rocky
described what it'd
be like for someone
to come into Arthur's office.
First of all, he had
this round table built,
King Arthur round table.
Guess who was the king?
DAVE LANGERT: Not subtle.
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah, right.
So Arthur would be
sitting at his desk.
Nothing on it.
Pencil.
And someone would come in,
and Arthur kept the air
conditioning at, like, 50.
And so immediately-- the person
comes in all cocky, you know,
I'm going to get a great deal.
And after a few minutes,
shifting around,
uncomfortable--
Arthur's up higher,
and Arthur would say,
I need to make some phone calls.
I'll be right with you.
And he'd make 25 phone calls.
And the person was
just sitting there.
And then Arthur would
put down the phone
and look up at the guy.
And he had a sharpened pencil,
and he would point the pencil
at the person.
And he had these glasses.
He would put on
glasses and take off--
this ritual.
And Rocky was like, it's
psychological warfare.
And this story about Rocky was
he came in with a bad report,
and this is how--
so he came in, went
through the whole routine.
And the report was just
sitting on the desk,
and Arthur didn't say a word,
made 40 calls, Rocky thinks.
And then he said,
I'll be right back.
I'm going to go to the bathroom.
Then we'll talk.
So Rocky's sitting there, and
45 minutes later, no Arthur.
And Rocky went to the secretary.
He's like, is he still here?
And they said, no,
he went to dinner.
That's his grandson.
And that's how he
let him know he
wasn't happy with the report.
So that's Arthur.
Gives you a little
taste of Arthur.
DAVE LANGERT: That's
just the beginning.
But really, in one of the
reviews of "The Breakaway",
Rick Hogan says that
this story has enough
dysfunction for a couple
of Eugene O'Neill plays.
So coming from this
figure, Arthur,
how did all the
dysfunction lay out?
And can you go into detail
about that family dysfunction?
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah.
I mean, Arthur is
the author of it
because he set out
the succession plan.
Arthur was an old school guy.
So he said when I die, the
oldest son inherits the team.
That was Bill.
And that succession plan
extended three generations.
So when Bill died, no
matter what Bill wanted,
Rocky was the eldest,
and he got the team.
And so right there
Bill resented kind
of being ruled from the
grave by his grandfather.
But the reason for
the Eugene O'Neill--
I wish I'd written that line.
It's great-- is
so Rocky's brother
Peter was with the
Blackhawks for decades
and was almost to the point
of obsequious to Bill.
He would never question Bill.
And had he taken
the team, he would
have made none of the changes
that led to where we are today.
And it was a good
thing because Bill--
I got in a little
trouble with this
before, but Bill is a little
Trumpian in the way that--
there's good old Dollar
Bill, as they called him,
for his cheapness.
He wouldn't put the games on TV.
Drove people insane.
And he was defiant about it.
He'd rub your face in it.
And you just couldn't say a word
against Bill or you were out.
And Rocky did.
He was the one person.
So Bill shuffled Rocky
off to run the liquor,
excommunicated him from
the team, basically.
And Peter ran it, but
he didn't do anything.
Bill ran everything and ran
the team into the ground.
So it got so bad,
how Bill treated
Rocky, he wrote a
letter to Rocky's
kids, his own
grandchildren, and said,
don't bother showing
up for Thanksgiving,
and I'll send you
the Christmas gifts.
I mean, that's
his own grandkids,
and wrote other
ugly stuff to them.
And there's a restaurant,
and Rocky would come in--
there's a restaurant
at the United Center,
and Bill would be holding court
over here with other family
members.
And Rocky would be over in
the corner with his wife
and maybe one of his kids.
And they never even
looked at each other.
It's crazy and ugly.
DAVE LANGERT: You alluded
to this maybe a little bit,
but why?
Why do you think Bill
treated Rocky so poorly?
BRYAN SMITH: It really
is because Rocky
was the one person
who dared cross Bill,
confront him, and
didn't back down.
And you just didn't do that.
I mean, if you look at all
of the people in Bill's
inner circle, they
were all yes men.
There was no one who
would stand up to him.
And Rocky just couldn't do it.
So he bided his time.
And I think part
of it, too, Rocky
was watching the team
just in free fall.
And he frankly
didn't want his name
associated with this
Hindenburg, this disaster.
And so he stayed out, did great.
The irony is-- with
the liquor side,
the irony is when the
team, as it went down,
it was pulling money out of
the liquor side to prop it up.
DAVE LANGERT: And Rocky didn't
have just a rough relationship
with Bill.
His relationship with
Peter is deeply fraught,
you mentioned even
going back to childhood.
What was that all about?
And do you think they'll ever
actually mend the fences?
BRYAN SMITH: No, I don't.
They don't talk to this day.
And Peter-- when they were kids,
they had a falling out over--
it's kind of this
lurid little side story
that Peter had dated
this much older woman,
by a couple of decades,
and moved out of the house.
And the family, the parents
were crushed, and Rocky was mad.
And Rocky came home from
college and confronted Peter,
and he said--
I think it was a holiday party.
Peter was wearing a tie,
and he pulled the tie out,
Rocky did, and said lesson one,
don't wear a tie to a fight.
And from that moment on they
were kind of at each other.
And then later,
when Bill and Peter
were huddling together and
plotting against Rocky,
here's probably one of the
most ugly and shocking things
that really had not
come out before,
was that Bill and Peter were--
I don't think it's too strong
a word to say scheming or--
DAVE LANGERT: Conspiring?
BRYAN SMITH: Conspiring
against Rocky.
Whispering campaign.
You can't trust Rocky
to other relatives,
just spreading scurrilous
rumors about him.
I mean, their own family member.
My god, you know?
And so yeah.
And when the father
died, and it was clear
that Rocky was going
to take the team,
Peter said I'm not going
to make the changes.
I'm not going to go
against Dad's wishes.
And Rocky said well, then
I can't make you president.
I'd love your help, but--
and that really, finally
completely severed
the relationship.
Peter had actually gone
behind Rocky's back
and asked if there was anything
in the will, Bill's will,
that the team was left to
him, and did stuff like that.
It was just a mess.
But Rocky took over
and never looked back.
It's like, if you're not
going to help me, OK.
But I'm going to change
this team dramatically.
DAVE LANGERT: And the
family dysfunction
wasn't the only thing
that was dysfunctional.
Bill had been known as
a shrewd businessman
for most of his life.
But toward the end, and
certainly at the point when
Rocky took over, not
just the Blackhawks,
but the entire
corporation was really
in jeopardy of going under.
What happened?
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah.
Yeah.
The whole organization
was tottering.
I mean, you have to remember
that this was '07, '08 was when
the real estate crash happened.
So the economy is plummeting.
Meanwhile the
Blackhawks are drawing
4,000, 5,000 people a night
in a 20,000 seat arena,
selling no merchandise.
And part of it is
Bill's stubbornness.
Bill thought the way
back to profitability
was that he'd cut his way
back to profitability.
So he cut staff, cut staff,
cut staff, cut expenses.
Just the TV thing got to be
almost like this weird point
of pride with him.
He just wouldn't give in on it.
Merchandise, they didn't have
any marketing department.
When Rocky took over the team,
on his first visit around,
there's phones ringing.
No one's answering the phones.
And the phone that went to
season tickets, he found out,
didn't actually ring
through to anybody.
It just went off into nowhere.
They didn't have post-its.
Like Rocky is walking through.
He's like, can I get
a bottle of water?
And no, we've got a
cooler in the corner.
It's like I don't guess
you have post-its, do you?
I don't know.
Maybe someone in a desk.
That was what the
business had come to.
And Rocky-- I won't
draw parallels here.
But Rocky's philosophy
was you've got to spend.
You've got to get
great staff, and you've
got to make things attractive
to attract that great staff.
Bill thought we don't
want to spoil the players
and get them their
own charter plane.
They're too spoiled.
Rocky though, well,
we're not going
to get these star players if we
have these crappy locker rooms.
We don't have a sales staff.
So how are we going
to sell tickets?
So he changed everything.
And it seemed like
it was overnight.
But the difference--
I think they've sold out
probably more than 500 games
in a row now, from
4,000 a night to 20,000.
So that's the difference.
DAVE LANGERT: Yeah.
And you described it a
little bit about this,
but the challenges
that Rocky faced when
he took over the Blackhawks.
You already mentioned just the
office infrastructure, but just
the general perception as well.
Can you go into just
how the Blackhawks
had become an afterthought?
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah.
You alluded to it.
They were named the worst
franchise-- not just hockey,
in all of sports--
by ESPN.
Bill Wirtz, I think, was
named the worst owner.
Rocky learned a few
days after he took over
that they were losing
$30 million cash a year.
Six days into Rocky taking over,
they couldn't make payroll.
And they had to make a capital
call to the liquor company
just to meet payroll.
Again, the national economy is
plunging, and Rocky is going,
this isn't sustainable.
It could take the whole
company down because they were
in banking, they
were real estate,
two terrible businesses
to be in '07, '08.
And on the surface, what
we all saw was, oh, gosh,
the guy made all
the right steps.
And it's fated.
Dale Tallon had already
picked these great players,
and it's fated to turn around.
But really, there must
have been 50 points
where if it had
gone another way,
they may have sold the team.
They may have moved the team,
original six hockey team.
And so he was facing Everest.
DAVE LANGERT: Coming out of
that, I mentioned earlier
"Forbes" called it
the greatest sports
business turnaround in history.
So what lessons do you think
can be learned from a business
perspective, and how
Rocky changed things
from what Bill had run?
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah.
I think quickly,
the one thing is--
yeah, it's awesome.
He let me, by the way,
take some pictures
with the cup by myself.
It was really cool.
He had remembered
that I wrote the story
and invited me to the office,
like come take some pictures.
DAVE LANGERT: I doubt Bill
would have done the same.
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah.
Bill would have done it, yeah.
Get over here.
So business lessons.
We alluded to it.
Cutting your way to success
versus investing smartly.
Rocky says the best
thing he ever did
was hire John McDonough,
the amazing marketing whiz
from the Cubs.
His best sell job, Rocky says.
So that's one lesson.
The other lesson
is recognizing--
it's sort of reading the
room, embracing your fans
and knowing how hurt they are.
Rocky said it wasn't
that we were just bad.
We were irrelevant.
No one cared.
And so embracing the
fans by bringing back
Stan Mikita and Bobby Hull,
mending all these fences.
When Rocky took over he said,
we were in the grudge business,
and we're not going to succeed
being in the grudge business.
There is a business
upside to treating people
right and treating people well.
And the outpouring, I think--
Rocky was a rock
star for those years.
I mean, he could barely walk the
concourse without being mobbed.
And it was because
he had this team
that we grew up with and
loved and watched them--
Bill-- stick his thumb in our
eye and take that from us.
And Rocky-- of course, it
was cast of thousands--
but gave that back.
This is a team generations
grew up loving.
And he gave that back, and
that's pretty powerful.
DAVE LANGERT: And
Bill never would
have walked the concourse.
He always watched
from his suite.
And he had an aisle
seat in the 100 level
where anyone could come up.
BRYAN SMITH: Rocky, yeah.
DAVE LANGERT: There's a cute
story about a little boy that
approached him.
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah,
completely different.
Yeah, Bill holed up in
his office with scotch--
he drank a lot--
and Peter, and just watched
another horrible game.
And
DAVE LANGERT: So I have
a couple more questions.
But I'd like to open
it up if any of you
have questions you want to ask.
AUDIENCE: So
obviously is an expose
that airs a lot of
family dirty laundry.
Rocky was on board.
How is the rest of the family?
Did Peter and everyone come
to you, like, don't do this?
What was the reaction
from everyone else?
BRYAN SMITH: Yeah,
it's a great question.
And as a corollary, a lot
of people have asked--
and I wonder, found
myself wondering--
look, I'm a journalist.
I mean, I'm paid to dig
out this kind of stuff.
But a couple of times it
was so painful to hear.
I was like, are you sure?
I mean, are you good with this?
And he said put it all in,
Rocky did, to his credit.
And so yeah, the siblings.
As I say, Rocky
and his siblings--
I think he occasionally talks to
his sisters, but not to Peter.
And none of them
would talk to me.
And I really tried because
I knew Peter really came off
looking bad in the story.
But you have to be fair.
And I told him, I can tell
the story, or your story,
or these people can tell
your story, or you can.
It's weird.
It's almost like he
had a psychic break,
like PTSD or something.
He just cannot--
when he was leaving,
he left this beautiful, gracious
letter saying how much he loved
the team and pledged his
loyalty and life to the team.
But after Rocky started
making all the changes,
he stopped coming to games.
He divested of anything having
to do with the Blackhawks.
He's still on the
board of Wirtz Corp.,
but doesn't have
anything to do with them.
It's just really weird.
He didn't come to
any of the parades.
Stanley Cups.
That's sad.
And they actually sued Rocky
for some little dumb thing
after they'd won
a couple of cups.
So fortunately I did
find some relatives,
like Bill's sister,
Rocky's aunt, who backed up
Rocky's side of the story.
And she was very,
very Aunt Betty.
Not to be messed with.
And she told it.
And so yeah.
And also, why would Rocky--
he spent a lot of
money promoting this.
Why would he push
something that is so
filled with these
intimate family details?
And I'm still not sure.
I think he wants
it to be a legacy.
He wants a story out
there to be known.
And his half of the royalties
do go to the Blackhawks
Foundation, which is good.
it's not like he's trying
to make money off of this.
I mean, me, charity
begins at home.
DAVE LANGERT: There will be
books for sale in the back.
BRYAN SMITH: We
have books for sale.
Makes a great Christmas gift.
And I'll be thrilled
to sign them for you.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Bryan.
Thanks for coming in.
I'm excited to read your book.
BRYAN SMITH: Oh, good.Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So this
is the perspective
of a newer Blackhawks fan.
So I didn't grow up--
I was too young to know
the Arthur and Bill eras.
So I find the time line
really interesting,
and you alluded to
this at the beginning,
because the dominoes
were starting
to fall a little bit
in the right direction.
During Bill's
final few years yes
they drafted a guy named
Patrick Kane, a guy named
Jonathan Toews in back-to-back
years, kind of important.
And you had Stan Bowman, who
was already in the organization
kind of rising up already.
Just from your perspective, if--
maybe take away the
huge debt that they
were in that kind of
Rocky found out about.
But if Bill is still
on the team for, say,
all the way another
five years, how
do you think that plays out?
I mean, they're still
probably competing
for a Stanley Cup championship.
BRYAN SMITH: It's
a great question,
and people ask it a lot.
Dale Tallon made a
lot of those moves,
and he got fired shortly
after Rocky came on board.
He did something,
just a business
decision that was terrible.
It's in the book, cost
the team millions.
And he just-- he had a
decent eye for talent,
but he didn't know
what he was doing.
Any more, General Manager has to
be a really shrewd businessman.
Rock's answer would be-- and
McDonough's and everyone else--
is that we had stars before.
We had a lot of
stars, great players,
and we were in last
place every year.
So it's hard to say.
I definitely don't
believe they would
have been the kind
of cup contenders
that they were because part
of what took that corps
and made it into that--
you remember that first cup
team was so deep
with great players.
Dustin Byfuglien, right?
I mean, the Buff, Big Buff.
And what attracted
those players,
though, was sellout
crowds every night
and brand new locker
rooms and a new charter
jet and big salaries.
Maybe overpaying
for some players.
So I really do believe
it wouldn't have played
out anywhere near the same.
They probably would have
had a little blip maybe up.
But as you know, it
shot up and sustained.
It's a long time, 10 years,
11 years, to be on the top.
They're struggling now.
So yeah.
It's a great question, though.
DAVE LANGERT: Go ahead, please.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I'm just curious.
I mean, much of this has
been about how many negatives
that Rocky has pulled
from Bill and his family.
Is there anything that he
mentioned that he did take away
as a positive that he attributes
some of his success to as well?
BRYAN SMITH: From his family?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
It's a great question.
A lot of people--
all the people I
talked to say Rocky
is a lot more like
his grandfather.
His grandfather was
a tough SOB, but he
wasn't like Bill, sort of just
belligerent to be belligerent
just because he kind
of got off on it.
Arthur was-- at the end,
it was all about business.
And Arthur actually
admired Rocky
because he saw Rocky
was standing up
to Bill when no one else would.
And so rocky definitely says he
took those lessons from Arthur,
mostly.
And we get into
this a little bit.
Rocky's mom is kind of
a shadow figure, right?
I mean, he had a mom.
And she was terrific.
She was terrific, Joan.
She died young of breast cancer.
And she was the
only other person
who could put a check on Bill.
And she was compassionate.
She was fun.
She invited Rocky's
friends over.
And Rocky took a lot,
I think, from her.
That's where I think--
it's like how, after
all these tough guys,
does Rocky turn out to be this
kind of really super great guy,
tough but good guy?
And I think she had a lot to
do with that in the family.
So I would say those
two influences for sure.
DAVE LANGERT: So what do
you think the future holds
for the Wirtz Corporation?
Rocky has a son, Danny.
He's an interesting
character in the book.
Do you think he'll ultimately
take over the corporation?
BRYAN SMITH: Well, it is
an interesting question
for all you Blackhawks fans,
what is going to happen.
First of all, Danny
is a good guy.
He's a super smart guy.
Sorry-- he's not a Peter.
He's a smart guy
who would never be
in the grudge business in the
way that Peter and Bill were.
And he is an interesting story.
Oop, did I lose--?
When he was a young guy,
he was like rebel guy.
He moved to London.
He was in the music business.
Colored hair, leather,
the whole thing.
And I think he got a nose ring.
And Rocky put the
foot down there.
It's like, OK, you can
keep the nose ring,
but I'm taking the car.
One or the other.
And so he took
the nose ring out.
And that gets back to
the business piece of it.
So Danny grew up in
like Google times,
very tech savvy, very immersed
in tech and the emerging
digital music.
And so he's really--
he'd be great.
He's poised to take over.
And he's running, essentially,
the liquor side now.
But that succession plan of
Arthur's ended with Rocky.
So it's kind of
up in the air now.
I think Rocky would
love Peter to take over,
and Peter would want to do it.
I mean-- Peter.
Danny.
But we don't know.
We'll have to see
how it plays out.
I think it may wind
up in court, actually.
DAVE LANGERT: One
thing that struck me--
you kind of brought it to mind
when you were discussing just
how Rocky borrowed
a lot from Arthur.
My impression reading the book
is that Bill and Rocky both ran
the organization and
the Blackhawks the way
they viewed Arthur
would want it to be run.
And they just had
completely different views
as to what Arthur
would really like.
And maybe it's the way that
he interacted with them,
but what are your
thoughts on that?
BRYAN SMITH: Anyway, we've
only got a couple minutes left,
so we're good.
We're good.
By all means, just shout out
a question if you have it.
But yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
I think that's what
made Bill so bitter
was being rules from the
grave, as Rocky put it,
by his father, Arthur.
He just couldn't
stand it that there
was nothing he could do to keep
the team out of Rocky's hands.
And Bill planted these
stories in the paper.
And so did Peter, kind
of spoke coyly when
people would say, well,
who's going to take over
when you die, Bill?
Well, we don't know.
We don't really talk about that.
And Peter would say things
like, well, I don't know,
but I would be
honored, of course.
And I love the team and I've
been with them for a while,
and I'd be great.
DAVE LANGERT: But we don't know.
BRYAN SMITH: And Rocky told
me, he's like, oh my god.
He said he would
read that, he'd go
that's the one thing we talked
about was the succession plan.
Everybody knew it.
It was no mystery.
And as hard as Bill
and Peter tried--
and they tried everything.
Lawyers.
They looked for any
loophole crack they could
find in that succession plan.
They just couldn't do it.
And I think it drove Bill crazy.
And I think that's
part of why he just--
I mean, can you
imagine doing that?
Like I'm sorry, I don't
mean to be political,
but can you imagine taking
a team, just because
of your personal feelings and
hurts, a franchise, beloved,
and just wrecking it,
just letting it go?
And actually there's
one other thing.
And it's interesting
for Hawks fans to know,
and it hadn't come out.
I hadn't known.
Bill had dementia
in the last days.
It was escalating, and he
was still running the team.
So a lot of his
decisions were informed
by this escalating dementia.
And there's an
anecdote in the book,
and it was really super sad.
Bill knew Chicago
like a taxi driver,
and he was supposed to be
at a board meeting downtown.
And he called in.
He was half an hour late and
he called--and he's never late,
and he called and
he said, I'm lost.
I don't know where
the meeting is.
And whoever answered the phone
said, well, where are you?
And he said Joliet, I think.
He was supposed to be
downtown in the Loop.
And yet he's still ran the team.
And Rocky covered for him.
The family tried to not let it
out that this was happening.
And that's kind of a
weird thing to know.
It gets back to you
asked, what happened?
Bill wasn't perfect.
But in his day, he was
a great business man.
But toward the end he was
just making crazy decisions,
like I think they were going to
put a Walmart near the family
farm out there.
And so he's like, yeah, buy
a bunch of shares in Walmart
so I can get on the
board and give 'em hell.
It's like, OK.
OK, Dad.
And they wouldn't do it.
So anyway.
DAVE LANGERT: Well, on that note
I think we can conclude this.
We have a video of Blackhawks
players reading the book
that we'll close off on.
There are copies
available in the back.
BRYAN SMITH: Makes a
great Christmas gift.
DAVE LANGERT: Yep.
And it's also available on
Amazon and other bookstores.
BRYAN SMITH: Yes, indeed.
DAVE LANGERT: Thank you.
BRYAN SMITH: Thank you.
It was fun.
Thanks, you guys.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I just bought this for my Dad.
It's going to make a great gift.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]